the man is at a Rehabilitation Center in
Las Vegas learning how to walk again
after suffering severe burns to about 15
percent of his body that's right he
jumped into a hot springs in round
mountain located about 300 miles
Northwest of Las Vegas to rescue his dog
Joshua peguero checks in on the man's
progress
there's no way there's just no damn way
I'm going back in for David neck has no
regrets about his actions on October
25th to try and save his dog Sasha's
life I took a couple more steps in and
I'm slowly just getting scalded the
whole time but I just refused to stop I
refused to stop until I had her and I
grabbed a collar and pulled her out the
incident left David with second-degree
burns below his knees he was visiting a
friend's place when his five-year-old
German Shepherd jumped into a hot spring
I looked at her and then I saw her start
to go limp and I was just like you know
what there's just there's no way Sasha
didn't survive despite David's best
efforts David spent about a month at the
UMC burn center before transferring to
Encompass Health where he's hoping to
regain the muscles in his legs through
intense physical therapy and learn how
to walk
CEO of Encompass Health says it will
take a patient like David one to two
weeks to get back on his feet we tend to
see pretty pretty substantial and pretty
quick improvement with our patients
because we provide so much intervention
by his side throughout the
rehabilitation and she has been since
the accident occurred will be his wife
Mary Lou we're very we're very lucky
that we've had the resources available
to us
to help take care of him
well after our original story aired and
Mary Lou says a couple who breeds German
Shepherds offer to donate them a new
puppy well David and Mary Lou say they
will surprise their kids with the pup
once David leaves rehab